démarrant
à
coc
alors
ouais si larry hagman
les bons soirs bon choix vous êtes pour
l'éternité larry un beau fumier un beauf
unis on peut le dire 10 ha et wing
l'homme le plus haï de la télévision yes
yes
et vingt ans après votre assassinat
devant 380 millions de téléspectateurs
vous publiez vos mémoires ça s'appelle
lots darling les mémoires impitoyable de
jr et c'est chez michel lafon laurent
montrez lui comment on fait alors
comment expliquer un fumier la promo
une honorine c'est le mot que vous
disiez à sue ellen à chaque fois que
vous la voyez
bien je te tue
alors b lindo sava ces nouveaux
traducteurs pour sommes maintenant un
bel hymne d'osama bin dans sa marche
dire que c'est moi qui fais la manche la
wii
comme ça on a plus de chance
les cartes comme ça parce qu'il va avoir
de la chance parfois je n'ai bien
rires ce livre est dédié à votre épouse
à votre co auteur qui s'appelle todd
gold et aux donneurs anonymes de votre
foi
nièce vous vivez à 70 ans depuis six ans
et demi avec le foie d'un homme de 35
ans et ça marche non chez et c'est pas
le week-end bref c'est un x portoricaine
soit quoi partir d'un port j'ai d'abord
ça colle
[Applaudissements]
car ils avaient dopé elle donc le 23
août 95 l'opération a duré seize heures
il y avait 5000 personnes qui
attendaient un foie rein en même temps
que vous est-ce que ça a été plus facile
pour vous qui est une énorme star
d'avoir un foie
à l'hôpital mon docteur aurait risqué la
réputation elle a été remis pratiqués
pour le faire
vous êtes informatique mais lorsque
numéro soeur ça y est
moi
et pour elle il était trop gros
dans son coeur donc c'est moi qui lui et
ça marche très bien chez moi ils sont de
belle taille les fois partant de rien
ils sont connus pour ça
tant mieux maintenant que lorsque j'ai
40 ans je jouais pas mal à ce moment là
oui il faut dire que vous buviez au
moyen âge une moyenne que je donne trois
bouteilles de champagne par jour
fin
mai les jours
et les bulls pendant 15 ans pendant
quinze ans et a duré et là vous étiez
tellement fou d'alcool que vous mettiez
du bourbon sur vos corn flakes le matin
au palais des congrès
les chasseurs et patrick vidal
surprendront de crise de bourbon cette
histoire m'a poursuivie depuis les faits
une fois à une fois abandonné dans la
tequila
bien sûr alors qu'en fait on apprend en
lisant votre livre qui est fort
intéressant on apprend que quand vous
étiez enfant vous avez été élevé par une
nurse une femme noire vous dites tout
ronde et pour vous endormir
elle était ni la veilleuse du gaz alors
il ya du gaz qui se répandait dans la
pièce et ça vous assoupi c'est donc
voilà comment comment ils étaient
endormis tant dormi au gaz quand j'étais
petit
ça marchait mais c'est qu'une fois elle
et elle s'est endormie aussi voilà un
soir évidemment il ya les parents donc
delahaye qui rentre d'une fête
paroissiale et qui vous découvre évanoui
dans une nappe de gaz alors évidemment
il a fallu trouver autre chose et cette
nurse a une très très bonne idée elle a
mis du sucre dans un sac en toile et
ensuite elle a plongé le sait un petit
peu l'outil grégory gala elle a plongé
le sac en toile dans du bourbon et le
donnait à téter à larry hagman
pourquoi je suis alcoolique voilà et
d'ailleurs dès l'âge de 18 19 ans votre
maire larry vous jette dehors un jour où
vous arrivez bourré aux jeans cette fois
et non pas aux bourbons et elle vous
jette dehors avec 50 $ par semaine
et 50 de leurs c'était assez bon mais à
l'époque et vous vous retrouvez donc en
train de bosser dans un cirque vous
apprenez à planter les mâts
du cirque perché sur une échelle très
compliqué à faire ça
demain
c'est au et jean-michel
marteau un gros marteau et vous taper
dessus grâce est clair mais surtout on
part en avant est alors un jour toujours
à l'époque où je travaillais dans le
cirque vous allez déguisé en lion avait
déguisé en lion et puis il ya un enfant
qui qui tire la queue du lion mais en
fait pour que l'air que jane bien à
droite qu'à un fil de fer qui passait
autour du cou donc quand le gosse jana
que ça faisait trop
les problèmes des pièces détachées en a
que le soir
donc la rive je continue votre vie à
l'époque vous vivez avec une chanteuse
nymphomane
départ mais on se balader ensemble
non je raconte ça je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que je voudrais
dépucelage c'est à dire qu'effectivement
votre père vous emmène dans un bordel
alors il ya une très belle phrase c'est
les murs étaient tapissés de st mais
elle saillie nts de saints et de
guirlandes de noël
j'ai agité
et ben c'est la première fois que vous
voyez une fille nue et faut dire les
choses vous n'arrivez pas à bander qua
non
c'est vrai nom jeffry jc le regarder car
il est difficile
yamada c'est un peu timide et le métro
elle n'est pas obligée de jaillir du
premier congrès
enfin rien tout est à vendre mais
ailleurs la larry et une super idée il
dit la fille voilà je vais te donner 5
dollars de plus et tu vas dire à mon
père que je suis un super bon étalon un
super bon coup et votre père vous a
félicité en plus c'était l'époque vous
étiez votre premier sert à
la fille était contente et moi j'étais
très bien aussi
c'est dans quel épisode
justement voilà déjà comment il était
effectivement il était capable de donner
chaque dollar est une fille pour qu'elle
dise qu'il avait honoré comme il faut en
fait après ça va très bien parce que dd
que vous êtes en fac vous devenez la
cible sexuelle de l'école
c'était si difficile mais il fallait le
faire
alors là bon maintenant on a vu l'alcool
on a vu le sexe on va passer la drogue
si vous êtes d'accord
l'actif de fish il assure la drogue
il serait votre jauge non en fait voilà
comment ça s'est passé je préfère dire
les choses tout à fait clairement vous
êtes en tournage à acapulco avec jack
nicholson et vous buvez énormément et un
jour nicholson vous dit tu devrais
essayer la l'herbe locale qui s'appelle
l'acapulco gold c'est différent vous
avez fait l'amour avec votre femme
j'ai essayé
fait autrement voulait donner 5 de leurs
6 et donc vous est alors sérieusement
vous êtes
vous êtes en lévitation à ce moment là
c'est à dire que cette herbe étaient
tellement fortes que larry était à celle
du sol carrément lévitation
je pensais qu'il était bien on a
retrouvé six
corps dont il ya un moment donc vous
fumez cette terre vous êtes en
lévitation et c est à un moment où vous
voyez un trou de 10 cm un trou avec du
ciel bleu au fonds vise quand même ces
termes elle est vraiment forte quoi je
vois un trou dans le mur quand même et
en fait pas du tout c'était un
tremblement de terre
et surtout des murs est ouvert j'ai
ainsi dit c'est formidable donc là on a
vu l'herbe alors quelques années plus
tard effectivement vous avez des
angoisses j'avais des angoisses vous
décidez d'aller voir un psy
ça a duré trois ans avec le psy à 100
dollars la séance quand même temps bien
il a rien trouvé
je vais pas vous dire
par tous les cas et c'est toujours la
même chose il vous est toujours larry tu
vis dans une prison dorée voilà ce
qu'ils disent eh bien
c'est tout ce qu'ils disent est en même
temps ce devis pablo weinrich est non il
l'a
dit inquiète
et quittez pas je suis jamais
keita lorsque c'est le petit a dit
finalement à larry hagman
tu n'as pas besoin de thérapie tu fais
je devrais prendre des
c'est incroyable c'est vrai qu'il ya un
doctorat ben
oui
et alors là c'est crosby parce qu'il
connaît que des stars l'arrivée devant
c'est crosby de crosby stills nash and
young qui vous donne vos premiers acides
donc un soir après un concert et puis
vous en a donné une poignée à c'était
vraiment généreux généreux pas chiche
avec mesa
sinon je recommande à tous les lecteurs
de livres de larry hagman je peux pas le
faire on n'a pas le temps les
descriptions
d'hallucinations à l'acide
extraordinaire de toute façon le livre
est livré avec un ou deux ans
non c'est
vous dit en parlant de cette expérience
la yagg man il ne m'était jamais rien
arrivé d'aussi bons le lsd m'avait
délivrer de ma crainte de la mort
c'est vrai j'ai fait depuis la loi
perben gelabale peur de la douleur n'est
pas de la mort ouais
pourquoi mais ça s'est compliqué et
suède
on meurt pas en fait
notre existence
et là vous avez senti en prenant s'est
assis vous avez senti que faisait partie
du tout du grand cosmos et que
finalement la mort c'était pas un
passage c'était un changement d'état
effectivement
ça se passe comme ça tout le temps
77 à magnéto serge chéri on a un
programme plus important que nous
occuper de ce que raconte ce compris
j ai laisse moi encore un peu de temps
je t'en prie
excepté pendant une soirée tu n'as pas
été dans mon lit depuis plus d'un an
alors comme temps ça suffit
jr je ne suis pas encore prête à ça ne
force pas
tout ce que je te demande c'est une
traite seulement comme tu te rates ton
petit copain
tout est là dedans mais là messieurs
alors laurie marc vous confie le script
de dallas laventure va durer treize ans
et en fait ça révolutionne la télévision
de l'époque
parce que c'est des gens qui étaient pas
sympa tire d'habitude à la télé il est
toujours des gens très sympas et là
alors c'est ce que vous dites à dans
dallas la grand mère est une vieille
[ __ ] le grand-père un [ __ ]
alcoolique et le frère un cavaleur et
vous bon très méchant évidemment c'est
pour ça que ça marche et non bien
c'est comme ça que j'ai travaillé dans
le modèle de girard c'est un texan que
vous aviez connu quand vous étiez au
texas un ami de votre père
multimilliardaire chez qui vous faisait
des petits boulots quand vous étiez
adolescent
un type assez durs qui avaient quatre
enfants et à sa mort les quatre enfants
se sont trucider pour piquer le
pognon du père et vous c'est l'aîné qui
vous a inspiré deux pour jouer le rôle
de jr en fait
naturel c'est vrai et à l'époque à
dallas vous dites il y avait des gens
bien plus méchant que ça il y avait des
vite il y avait des milliers de jr 100
fois plus méchant et moins charmant
pour par exemple de vie et pas parce
que c'est comme ça dans l'industrie
pétrolière
de ce qui se passe maintenant oui george
bush il était dans l'industrie
pétrolière la famille bush
si on retrouve maintenant oui ça c'est
sûr
alors il ya des gens qui aiment être
détesté effectivement c'est le cas de jr
il aimait détester laver pierre ouais
vous dites ça leur donne une impression
de pouvoir
et ses retables way
alors à l'époque quand vous étiez jr ou
au fait de votre gloire au sommet de
votre gloire est ce que dans la rue il y
avait des gens qui vous agresser en
disant qu'ils veulent qui vous tapez ou
qui vous insulter ou qui vous
restera dallas
de mon oeil vieille dame qui prive un
système aux avancées
du miroir et la prison sert
un coup de sac sur la tête
je suis tombé de ma chaise
ensuite j'ai bien qu'il ait fait dans
mon sac donc elle ne m'a cogné avec un
sac avec un présent ouais il ya un truc
que vous avez remarqué sur dallas que
j'avais jamais remarqué c'est qu'en fait
jr il habite toujours chez son papa et
sa maman michael nayrole chaîne si
jamais compris pourquoi
il y avait trois millionnaire
leurs femmes capitals une pièce avec une
seule salle de bain et s'agit jamais
compris pourquoi
pas pourquoi c'est comme le neuf trois
cent cinquante six épisodes 380 millions
de téléspectateurs pour le dernier
épisode c'est je crois jamais vu tout le
monde vous demande avait pas qui a tué
djiar et tout le monde nous disait alors
dis le moi dit de moi et des journaux
qui avait offert je suis combien de
milliers de dollars de centaines de
milliers de dollars et même la
reine-mère la pauvre qui vient de mourir
dieu ait son âme même la reine mère
vous a demandé
c'était al-mahdi
qui a tiré ce jazz j'étais désolé je ne
sais même pas et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque
le producteur avait tourné plusieurs
fins plusieurs solutions possibles il
avait tourné la mort avec tous les
acteurs pour brouiller les pistes
qui ne sut pas bio si ce n est ce qui
est tout le monde m'a tiré dessus
on a fait cinq semaines avant
elle même si j'ai payé je peux pas dire
les vérités mais je n'avais pas en fait
ouais c'est géniale idée hein ils ont
tourné plein de fins possibles c'est
extraordinaire comme idée il voulait
noyer bobby parler mais comme ils
n'agissent super bien
un pic à 2 hier c'est chez michel lafon
messieurs
alors on va voir maintenant larry hagman
comment va votre santé mentale qu'on va
faire l'interview psy
dans le bush mais pour l'heure on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle en bouche
car on ne bouge pas
le père fils mme
fages et galvanisent mes troupes et un
souci avec le bassiste
et d'un fils très bien c'est pas bien ça
me ferait bien aller on n'a pas
l'habitude de prendre les mooschois
alors attention
larry est ce que vous êtes mito
géologie magie n'a jamais joué non de la
sla
est ce que vous êtes mégalo
yash oui
parano
non est ce que vous êtes schizo mais bon
je n'ai l'orage mais les acteurs font
tout ça bonjour vous êtes d'accord
qui vous êtes bien est-ce que vous êtes
l'info
non pas encore
est ce que vous êtes maso non
j'aime pas la douleur sadow
night game pas faire donner de la
douleur est ce que vous êtes seaux d'eau
non
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos
je parle de ses coûts de ces groupes
armés
est ce que vous êtes trio
mais sa maison a bon
dos vous êtes à paris paris paris
je fais une seule banque est ce que vous
êtes homo
n'est pas plein de trucs à faire encore
est ce que vous êtes vous
êtes encore très flou
[Rires]
larry est ce que vous êtes rocco ou
chamallows
donc que la tragédie que j'ai trop connu
c'est une star du porno en france c'est
vrai world que tu chantes merde moi qui
ressemble à kent voilà pourquoi pas is
like us ce qu'il faut c'est bien mais il
faut un écran
là
merci beaucoup merci la deux
n'empêche c'est génial on remarque bien
toute ta vie comme un trou tu as eu cinq
bouteilles de champagne par jour pendant
15 ans n'a pas le réflexe d'acheter un
cheval un portoricain j'étais pas les
cours
enfants
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux